malgré la crise sanitaire la vie
démocratique reprend progressivement son
cours la proposition de loi pour
accompagner les familles après le décès
d'un enfant a été adopté ce soir
l'allongement du deuil à 12 jours on
n'avait pas fait l'unanimité on s'en
souvient en premier lecture avant le
confinement
on retrouve en direct notre reporter
tome abonné depuis le palais bourbon à
paris bon soir thomas
le parlement a donc donné son feu vert
unanime ce soir où une proposition de
loi adoptée à l'unanimité comme pour
corriger ce qu'il faut bien qualifier de
couac gouvernemental le 30 janvier
dernier la majorité et le gouvernement
s'était opposé à cette proposition de
loi visant notamment à allonger la durée
du congé de deuil pour enfants un refus
qui avait provoqué à l'époque de vives
réactions des réactions au sein de
l'opposition au sein du medef aussi et
surtout chez emmanuel macron le chef de
l'état qui avait alors demandé au
gouvernement de faire preuve d'humanité
sur ce sujet et si le texte avait été
refusée c'est en fait plus par des
réflexes politiciens que par une
véritable opposition de fond sur ce
sujet il faut dire que cette proposition
loi n'émanent pas directement de la
majorité elles émanent de guy bricout
qui est un député udi du nord nous
l'avons rencontré tout à l'heure avec
cynthia lauvergeon je vous propose de
l'écouter
j'ai madame pénicaud à côté de moi et je
disais même pénicaud attention je pense
que vous allez avoir des problèmes je ce
sens vous avez marre des problèmes parce
que je me répète j'étais aux côtés
d'associations qui attendaient beaucoup
de cette proposition de loi
je pense que peut-être la majorité n'a
pas voulu voter favorablement parce que
c'était dans le cadre des niches et
qu'on avait déjà eu plusieurs niches
d'accepter donc sera peut-être fait
comptablement trop de 2
proposition de loi pour nous rappeler a
rappelé à l'ordre par le chef de l'état
la majorité a donc voté ce texte qui a
été enrichie depuis par des amendements
du sénat y faut donc que maintenant
compter donc quinze jours de congés en
cas de deuil d'un enfant une allocation
forfaitaire pour les familles également
et puis seront considérés comme des
enfants dans le cadre de cette loi
toutes les personnes allant jusqu'à
l'âge de 25 ans je propose d'écouter à
nouveau guy pécou qui nous fait part de
la fierté et de la façon avec laquelle
il a travaillé pour cette proposition de
loi je suis en contact pratiquement
permanent avec les associations qui
s'occupent des parents endeuillés des
parents qui perdent un enfant en bas âge
ou en dessous de 25 ans emma loi c'était
de faire en sorte que l'on tienne compte
de la détresse de ses parents et puis qu
on allonge le congé de deuil pour
permettre aux parents de reprendre leur
souffle d'envisager l'avenir un peu plus
sereinement
c'est tout ça qui me fait décider j'ai
eu un grand écho on on est entouré de
beaucoup d'associations qui seront à mon
avis très attentive ce qui va se passer
tout à l'heure c'est donc à l'unanimité
que cette loi a été adoptée ce mardi et
certains députés de la majorité ont
reconnu l'erreur qui avait été la leur
pendant la première lecture de cette loi
c'était donc en janvier dernier on
imagine donc l'émotion de guy bricout
qu'on a vu d'ailleurs très émue les
larmes aux yeux lorsque le vote a été
annoncé un vote donc à l'unanimité ce
soir merci thomas bonnet à l'assemblée
nationale